Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, wolltest du eigentlich auch nochmal zum Mars fliegen?
Heute oder morgen.
Oder auch immer.
Ja ich äh ich lasse mal den Elon Musk vorfliegen.
Netzpolitik, die einhundertsiebzigste Ausgabe wieder gewohnt aus der Mieterebene,
Es ist früh, wie immer. Gefühlt doppelt so früh, also später aus dem Bett kommt,
Ja. Tja, Linus, ähm wie sieht's aus? Alles, alles im Lot?
Sogar hier geht's steil bergauf mit den Verlusten.
Was los? Hast du dich äh hast dich verspekuliert oder was?
Na, ich gucke hier so, ey. Ich muss den ganzen Morgen schon darüber lachen, dass man bei der Süddeutschen Zeitung, wenn man den Artikel.
Die haben den Titel geändert, die haben den Titel geändert bei der Süddeutschen Zeitung gab es heute Morgen einen schönen Artikel ähm,
mit dem Titel, ich habe viel Geld verschleudert, ja
Das ist ein Interview mit Harald Krasnitzer, dieser Tatortkommissar. Und wenn man da drauf klickt, kommt so eine Meldung
Lesen Sie jetzt den kompletten Artikel, Monatsabo neunzehn neunundneunzig. Tagespass eins neunundneunzig und der Artikel hat den Titel, ich habe viel Geld verschleudert. Das fand ich sehr witzig.
Und jetzt hat er aber jetzt hat er, wann äh eine andere Überschrift bekommen.
Äh das haben sie haben sie gemerkt, wie schlecht das rüberkommt?
Die Zeitungsbranche ist immer noch am ausloten, wie man,
Am besten mit der Zukunft klarkommt. Aber das ist ja hier auch unser Auftrag, nicht wahr? Auch wir versuchen hier die ganze Zeit auszutoten, wie wir mit der Zukunft klarkommen. Manchmal nicht ganz so einfach.
Nun ja, ähm was steht heute auf dem äh Programm? Wir haben äh so die eine oder andere Meldung
aber wir haben, wie es auch so in den letzten Sendungen schon häufiger der Fall war, haben wir äh ein Spezialthema äh am Start und für den Spezialthemen für das Spezialthema haben wir dann auch noch
den passenden Gas dazu. Und zwar begrüßen wir am anderen Ende der Leitungen ins Internet die Sandra, Sandra Troste, hallo Sandra.
Guten Morgen Sandra.
Sandra, ja, wer ähm dich nicht kennt, wir erläutern das mal äh kurz, du bist äh Dokumentarfilmerin, kann man das so sagen?
Ja, also das ist schon so dein Hauptding, ne?
Mhm. Und ähm um kurz vorwegzunehmen, du arbeitest grade an einem Dokumentarfilm Projekt,
was sich mit dem Chaos,
und in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein wenig mit dem Chaos Kongress oder sagen wir mal insgesamt mit dieser Chaos, Eventkultur äh beschäftigt,
Ähm.
Erzähl doch mal kurz, wie du überhaupt so äh in diese Rolle reingewachsen bist. Also wie lange machst du das schon und, und, und warum?
Genau, also ich meine, man muss ja schon irgendwann mal so eine Entscheidung fällen, dass dass diese Art von Filmerei, also Filmerei an sich und natürlich dann auch speziell Dokumentarfilme so der eigene Film sind.
Mhm. Was ja auch schon so äh die ein oder andere größere Produktion gemacht,
Wie kam's denn dann dazu, ähm dass dass du dich jetzt mit dem TCC auseinandergesetzt hast? Oder wie bist du auf auf dieses diese Idee gekommen,
beim Camp äh dich zu engagieren.
Aber wenn du sagst, du warst auf verschiedenen Kongressen, meinst du damit aber noch nicht, den Chaos Communication Kongress oder auch.
Wie war das so für dich? Also ich meine, was.
Er, das kenne ich irgendwo her. Okay und dann hast du ein ein Team zusammengestellt und dir einen Plan gemacht,
und äh war's dann ja auf dem Camp die ganze Zeit äh präsent, also ich hatte so den, ich weiß gar nicht, ab wann hast du das Camp begleitet, so richtig vom Aufbau an mit.
Wie waren so deine Erfahrungen mit,
mit dem Camp und den Campteilnehmern, also du hast ja schon angedeutet, es gibt ja da so grundsätzlich immer eine recht ähm äh soll ich sagen, verbreitet Zurückhaltung und natürlich auch mehr oder weniger klare,
regeln, dass wir den Leuten eben ihren, ihren Freiraum auch dahingehend äh sichern wollen, dass sie jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit von irgendwelchen Kamerateams abgefilmt werden, das war ja in der Vergangenheit auch häufiger mal wirklich ein,
und ähm manche verstehen das so auf den ersten Blick von außen natürlich auch äh dann nicht, weil man's halt anders gewohnt ist, ne? Normalerweise, man geht auf Events und macht halt, was man will. Das ist ja das schon ein bisschen anders.
Bist du da? Hast du dich da angenommen gefühlt? Oder.
Und hat gut geklappt.
Ich habe auch immer so, ich meine, ich hatte auch so das ein oder andere Mal schon mit Doku-Teams ähm äh meine Begegnungen gehabt und ich habe halt immer gemerkt, das funktioniert immer besonders dann gut, wenn so ein Team es schafft, eigentlich unsichtbar zu werden,
irgendwie dabei ist, aber äh keiner mehr das Gefühl hat, dass jemand dabei ist.
Hm. Ja, du hattest ja mal so eine, so eine, so eine grelle Jacke, wo hinten Dokuteam drauf stand.
Dann warst du auch noch mal aufm Kongress und äh ich vermute mal auch äh da ist Material entstanden, was letzten Endes in das Projekt äh einfließen soll, aber der Schwerpunkt liegt schon auf dem Camp oder kannst du das noch gar nicht sagen?
Mhm. Ja, aber es ist ja wirklich eine eine sehr schwer einzufangen der Atmosphäre, habe ich immer wieder festgestellt.
Das Projekt heißt All-Creaturs welcome, wie bist du auf den Namen gekommen?
Ja, da haben wir auch drüber gesprochen, ja?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das war. Also ich hatte ehrlich gesagt mit Kloschilder sind auch nur so im Rande mein.
Ähm ich habe mich da sehr wenig mit auseinandergesetzt und ich weiß tatsächlich nicht, ähm weiß ich nicht genau, ob die also von wem die waren oder wie die beim einunddreißig C drei aussahen, das weiß ich tatsächlich nicht.
Es steht ja auch in der Präambel der Satzung des Chaos Computerclubs e.V. Ne? Der CCC ist eine
Gemeinschaft von Lebewesen, unabhängig von Alter, Geschlecht und Rasse sowie gesellschaftlicher Stellung, die sich grenzüberschreitend für Informationsfreiheit einsetzt und mit den Auswirkungen von Technologien auf die Gesellschaft, sowie das einzelne Lebewesen
beschäftigt und das Wissen um diese Entwicklung fördert.
So jetzt äh ist das natürlich ein ziemlicher Aufwand, so einen Film zu machen,
Also da fließt äh einerseits natürlich viel äh Zeit rein, um das überhaupt alles erstmal zu filmen, aber natürlich dann auch später daraus einen richtigen Film zu machen. Und das kostet natürlich auch alles Geld. Und,
wir reden ja auch jetzt ähm also wenn wir jetzt von Filmen reden,
Wir reden jetzt schon von einem relativ langen Film. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob du da schon irgendeine Länge äh im im im Kopf hast, was am Ende dabei rauskommen soll.
Okay. Und äh das muss natürlich alles auch irgendwie finanziert werden. Und was war da jetzt der Plan?
Ja gut, ich meine, dafür muss man sich gar nicht äh groß rechtfertigen. Meine das, wenn man da jetzt irgendwie zwei Jahre an so einem Ding äh rumstrickt und äh natürlich auch viele andere Leute da noch mit äh einbezieht und äh natürlich dann auch äh mit äh finanzieren muss. Das ist ja äh vollkommen klar.
Was ähm also was war denn jetzt sozusagen deine Strategie? Also um vielleicht mal kurz zusammenzufassen, du hast ja ähm ursprünglich
glaube ich, das Ganze über Förderung äh angedacht,
kam halt der Gedanke mit dem Crowdfunding noch mit dazu und äh ein Hintergrund ist ja auch die Frage, ob
dieser auf welche Art und Weise dieser Film,
das Licht des Tages sieht, weil üblicherweise ist das ja so, solche Filme werden dann irgendwie gemacht und dann werden die irgendwie gefördert und dann kommen die vielleicht auch mal irgendwie ins Kino und dann laufen die in so ein paar Kinos für ein paar Wochen und dann sind sie irgendwie wieder weg. Und das ist natürlich,
gerade sagen wir mal für diese Szene nicht unbedingt so die Erwartungshaltung, die man jetzt an so eine Dokumentation hat, ne, zumal wir ja auch schon früher
selber kleine Dokumentationen selber gemacht haben. Es gab also von den früheren Camps, wirst du ja auch gesehen haben, gab's so zehn, fünfzehn äh äh Minuten äh äh,
Videos, die ähm
auch sehr aufwendig waren und die wir dann teilweise einfach aus äh unseren eigenen nicht vorhandenen äh Budget mitfinanziert haben, aber eben mit dem Vorteil, dass die Dinger halt im Netz sind und auch äh für immer im Netz bleiben werden.
Video on demand, ne?
Mhm. Das heißt, selbst, selbst wenn du alles Geld, was du bekommen hast, wieder zurückzahlst, hast du trotzdem noch die Auflagen für, wie das überhaupt verwertet werden kann.
Den gelten keine der Auflagen mehr.
Also dein Plan ist jetzt, du musst das mal ein bisschen auseinanderhalten, also Filmförderung,
Hast du quasi schon mal angeleiert, weil für dich ja nicht klar war, welche Option am Ende rauskommt, aber du würdest dir das gerne ersparen.
Und damit du dir das aber ersparen kannst, müsste im Prinzip die vollständige Summe, die eben so eine Produktion kostet, die jetzt bei ungefähr hunderttausend Euro taxiert ist, müsste zusammenkommen.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen das Ziel. Und du hast jetzt ähm ähm du hast jetzt eine eine Crowdfunding-Webseite aufgesetzt bei Indigo.
In die Gogo ähm ist ja, es gibt ja verschiedene Seiten. Man, was jeder kennt, ist so Kickstarter, die Gogo mögen vielleicht die einen oder anderen auch noch mal gehört haben. Das ist ja nicht ganz beliebig, weil diese ganzen Crowdfunding-Webseiten, die haben ja so eine,
Etwas unterschiedliche Politik und bei ist es ja so, dass man da halt Projekte machen kann, wo man sagen kann, hier ist mein Ziel,
Aber selbst, wenn ich das nicht erreiche, äh wird das gesammelte Geld ausgezahlt.
Mhm.
Okay, nur klarzumachen. Also, wenn man sich jetzt sozusagen beteiligen möchte, äh,
Kann man das machen, entweder über Indigo, wenn man PayPal Zahlen über PayPal zahlen kann und und und will. Wenn man es nicht will, gibt's noch die zweite Möglichkeit, über die andere Seite, die wir auch verlinken. Da kann man dann mit normaler Kontoüberweisung was machen,
sogar Bitcoin hast du jetzt irgendwie auch noch am Start.
Okay, also du kannst auch ein bisschen Unterstützung äh gebrauchen, was sozusagen das reinadministrative äh dieser dieser Spenden äh Geschichte äh betrifft. Aber vor allem geht's erstmal dadrum,
überhaupt, auf welchem dieser beiden Kanäle oder drei Kanäle äh auch immer äh sozusagen das Geld reinzubekommen, weil das würde dann bedeuten, wenn die ganze Summe zusammenkommt, also wenn's sozusagen auf die hundert, ist das jetzt die richtige Zahl, hunderttausend oder was.
Okay. Okay, also also hundert genau, also hundertfünfzehntausend, meine Idee.
Okay, sorry. Das ist nur mal.
Ja, na, ich meine, wenn schon, äh denn schon, ne? Also äh die hundertfünfzehntausend, wenn die zusammenkommen, dann bedeutet das, der Film ist finanziert, der Film ist komplett frei von Filmförderung,
und damit kannst du ihn und wirst ihn dann auch unter einer Creative Comments leistens veröffentlichen.
Das ist das Ziel.
Ja, das kennen wir ja natürlich auch alle und ich denke, da gibt's dann auch die entsprechende äh da fehlt dann jeder mit, ja. Hier in äh unserer Gemeinde.
Ja. Ja, das ist absurd. Und ähm ich glaube, dass man auch letzten Endes nur über solche Projekte,
wo man sich einfach mal diesen ganzen Apparat abschüttelt, auch zeigen kann, so hier es gibt gibt diesen Bedarf, so,
und euer Fördersystem ist irgendwie im Eimer, weil ihr eigentlich überhaupt nicht im Interesse der Öffentlichkeit agiert. Gut, ich meine, kann man sagen, ja, wieso ist ja auch Wirtschaftsförderung, ne?
Von vorne rein so gedacht, aber vielleicht ist es an der Stelle ähm müsste es vielleicht auch mal einen, einen anderen Ansatz geben,
um freie Kultur und äh Kunst zu fördern.
Ja, genau, das wollte ich.
Ja Sandra, ähm wir wünschen dir äh viel Erfolg mit diesem äh Projekt natürlich, würden wir es äh positiv vor allem sehr gerne, also erstmal will ich diesen Film sehen.
Zweitens ähm,
Und ich habe mir auch äh deine anderen Sachen angeschaut und äh habe da ein ganz gutes Gefühl, dass du da schon äh das richtige Händchen hast und vor allem will ich diesen, diesen Film halt
öffentlich sehen. Das ist natürlich dann auch grade, was jetzt den Club betrifft, natürlich auch ein Anliegen da ähm die,
ja, einfach mal auch diesen Blick.
Auf die Chaoskultur, die sind insbesondere diese Chaos-Eventkultur auch mal schön zu fassen und damit auch irgendwie auch ein Piece zu äh schaffen, was bleibt.
Okay Sandra, ich sage mal vielen Dank. Ähm wir haben äh alle Links hier äh natürlich in den und ja alles Gute für die Kampagne. Linus, hast du noch was hinzuzufügen?
Wir freuen uns natürlich auf den Film oder auf die Party.
Vor allem auf die Party, genau. Ich will nämlich auf die Party hier.
Das können wir gut, genau, ja, also wenn das klappt, dann werden wir da auf jeden Fall auch äh was abliefern, woran alle Spaß haben werden.
So, das war's. Äh zu dem Thema muss ich jetzt mal gesagt werden. Ja. Und jetzt steigen wir eigentlich erst mal so richtig in unser Programm ein. Das machen wir erstmal mit ein bisschen Feedback. Wir hatten auch welches, oder?
Wir haben äh sie wurden gehört, also wir müssen langsam vorsichtig sein mit was was wir sagen, was man mal machen müsste.
Meinst du, hört uns jemand zu?
Die hören uns zu. Und ähm,
Nelako hat es natürlich nicht auf sich sitzen lassen, dass wir das wäre natürlich ganz schön, wenn deine Darstellung,
auch irgendwie mit HTM, L, fünf und animiert und haste nicht gesehen. Und da gibt's jetzt ähm unter Nelako DE Slash geheime minus Köpfe,
Köpfe mit OE, nämlich genau das, äh wo man quasi sieht, äh,
Man kann nach Parteizugehörigkeit markieren oder nicht. Äh man kann, man hat die ähm,
die Rollen dort, Regierungen, Innenminister, Chef des Kanzleramts, BND-Präsident, Geheimdienstkoordinator und dann stehen da jeweils die Personen, die Personen sind farbig. Und wenn man jetzt auf eine Person klickt.
Kriegt man nochmal eine eigene Zeile, wo die jeweilige Historie äh.
Genau, kriegt man die Person farbig äh also dann kriegt man unten die Zeile der Person. Und das ist quasi genau das, was ich meinte, dass man eben,
Einerseits für jedes Amt sehen kann, wer hat das zu welchem Zeitpunkt besetzt? Und wenn man dann sieht, ah, Hans-Peter Friedrich, ja, der war,
Innenminister mal. Und sonst nichts. Und äh ähm.
Korreliert mit äh Ereignissen und.
Genau und unten.
So weiter. Da könnte man sicherlich noch ein paar mehr äh Sachen eintragen. Hier ist gegebenenfalls auch noch Unterstützung gefragt. Äh schaut euch das mal an und äh schätze mal hier äh,
würden entsprechende Angebote da noch mehr Daten einzutragen und das Ganze vielleicht ein bisschen auszubauen, äh durchaus gern gesehen werden.
Ja und das ist äh das ist ein schönes Ding. Das sieht man mal. Ach so und da gibt's, ach guck mal hier, ist aufgetaub und da kann man dann also äh sogar direkt äh hinschicken.
So haben wir das gerne.
So so gefällt uns das.
Genau, Firma jut. Dann äh fragen wir den Bundestag.
Fragt, fragt den, fragen wir den Bundestag. Also die die fragt den Saga.
In eine neue Runde.
Genau, immer nicht alles noch so fragen kann. Nachdem der Staat ja schon eifrig äh befragt wurde, befragt man jetzt mal etwas konkreter den Bundestag. Wo, was steckt dahinter? Irgendwas mit Gutenberg.
Die Geschichte geht geht los mit also eigentlich, also ähm.
Dein Freund.
Gutenberg hatte ja äh unter anderem plagiert,
aus einer Studie des ähm des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestages. Und ähm das war damals Auslöser für.
Ähm Anfragen nach diesen Werken. Da hatten wir auch glaube ich,
erinnere mich dunkel auch mal darüber gesprochen zu haben, dass man sagt, okay, wenn der der wissenschaftliche Dienst des Bundestages Wissenschaft betreibt, dann wär's ja,
fein, wenn äh diese wissenschaftlichen Erzeugnisse dann auch der Allgemeinheit äh zur Verfügung stünden.
Und da gab's dann also zwei Anfragen, die Auslöser waren für eine längere äh äh gerichtliche Auseinandersetzung. Ähm,
Die andere war eine äh Studie zu Ufus. Ja, wo auch klar war, die verheimlichen uns was, ja. Also es war die Studie nach Außerirdischem Leben,
und die Umsetzung der UN-Resolution zur Beobachtung unidentifizierter Flugobjekte und extrateressische Lebensformen, die da auch eingesehen werden sollte. Und jetzt hatte das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig im Juni entschieden,
Das Ausarbeitung des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes nach dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz des Bundes herausgegeben werden müssen, ja? Das heißt, dass,
Bundesverwaltungsgericht hat im Prinzip gesagt, du kannst, wenn du eine Informationsfreiheitsanfrage nach einer Studie,
des äh Wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestages stellst, dann soll muss dieser Stadt gegeben werden. Und.
Was super ist.
Genau. Und jetzt hat ähm.
Quasi der äh die die Webseite Abgeordneten Watch eine Liste mit den Titeln Tausender Gutachten des wissenschaftlichen,
des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestages ins Netz gestellt,
Haben gesagt, hier ist die Liste äh vermutlich aller oder aller äh Bekannten oder so. Ähm,
Also hier ist ein, haben einfach gesagt, hier ist eine Übersicht aller Gutachten des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestages.
Und ähm zeigen unter anderem unter anderem darauf aufmerksam, dass sich da eine Ausarbeitung zum unumstrittenen Freihandelsabkommen. TTIP
befindet, die der Bundestag als vertraulich eingestuft hat und so,
geben so einige der schönen äh einige schöne Beispiele, ja auch dass dass sie dann irgendwie nur für den Dienst Dienstgebrauch eingestuft wurden und so.
Und dann hat äh,
Wenn ich der Hintergrund ist, wenn du jetzt zu viel auf einmal anfragst, dann äh stellen die dir,
Also jetzt könnte man ja einfach auch frag den Staat gehen und sagen, ich hätte gerne einmal alle,
Und dann werden die dir das scheint mir der Hintergrund zu sein. Ich spekuliere,
Dann würden sie dir sagen, das ist zu viel, ja? Das ist äh ein.
Es sind mehrere Kilo weiter.
Sind mehrere, dass es zu viel Arbeit, ja? Das müssen sie bezahlen. Die haben ja sogar diese Liste, also auch wieder ein,
Ja, okay, das ist einfach so.
Die die wisst ihr auch wo wo der Hase lang läuft. So, die haben halt äh Abgeordneten Watch hatte diese Liste irgendwie angefragt, dann haben sie diese Liste bekommen, mussten aber vierundzwanzig Euro zwanzig bezahlen für zweihundertzweiundvierzig Kopien
Denn sie haben diese Liste ausgedruckt bekommen. Und dann musste die halt irgendwie wieder ähm.
Digitalisiert werden. Oh Gott.
Digitalisiert werden, also mit haben dann eine eine äh OCR drüber laufen lassen und was nicht alles auf jeden Fall letzten Endes gibt es jetzt unter Frag den Bundestag eine vereinfachte Plattform.
Wo du ähm quasi sagen kannst, mich interessieren Studien zum Thema,
äh habe ich nicht, haste nicht gesehen, sagst du jetzt zum Beispiel, also dann gehst du auf die Datenbank, da sind jetzt alle diese Studien drin, jetzt gebe ich zum Beispiel ein Internet,
Ähm dann gibt's da sehr viele, echt interessante Studien.
Und dann siehst du zum Beispiel eine Studie zweitausendzehn Internetsperren für kinderpornographische Inhalte. Und links daneben steht schon, Status warte auf Antwort. Das heißt, die hat schon einer angefragt. Ein eine Person,
und so macht es äh fragt den Bundestag jetzt einfach quasi die zu die Studien zu erkennen und die,
Schon angefragt wurden und die, die noch nicht angefragt wurden. Und jetzt kann man als äh eins individueller interessierter ähm Bürger oder Bürgerin.
Da mal eins, zwei, drei Anfragen,
das äh und dann steht auch direkt drin, digital reicht so, ne? Bemühen sie äh es ist in Ordnung, uns reicht ein Maschinen lesbares PDF, wir wollen es eigentlich am Ende eh nur auf frag den Staat äh äh,
gesammelt haben. Und äh so wird dann eben angestrebt eine vollständige online äh Bibliothek der Gutachten des Wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestages zu bekommen. Das das.
Das sinnvolle, das also das Sinnvolle wäre natürlich, wenn diese Studien einfach grundsätzlich ähm öffentlich wären und das ist eben dann so der Unterschied zwischen sage ich mal einem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und einem proaktiven,
Transparenzgesetz, wo nämlich wo du quasi sagst, nee, da musst du von vorneherein veröffentlicht werden. Aber hier eine wieder mal eine schöne Aktion von frag den Staat.
Ähm jetzt hier sehr wieder sehr gerockt von Arne Semsrott,
von der Orknoge Foundation, der davon ausgeht, dass wir das bis zum Ende des Jahres äh sollten alle Gutachten verfügbar gemacht werden können. Er weiß natürlich auch, wie äh wie solche Verfahren dann irgendwie verschleppt werden und so, ne.
Und jetzt geht dieses die quasi die das Verklag das fragt den verklagt den und so weiter, Universum natürlich wirklich schön Hand in Hand,
weil du quasi jetzt bei frag den Bundestag die ganzen Studienanfragen kannst und wenn du dann negative wenn du dann negative Rückmeldungen bekommst, dann hast du ja eben dieses Urteil von.
Bundesverwaltungsgerichtes.
Bundesverwaltungsgerichtes in Leipzig, auf das du dich berufen kannst, um dann direkt dir diese Dinge einzuklagen. Also das ist jetzt der Prozess, ist jetzt hier so gestreamt, dass es wirklich wird die Customer Experience hier ähm.
Also du musst die Plattform nicht verlassen, ne? Das ist so, du wirst.
All in one.
Hier die das Team um Arne Selmsrott,
hier anbietet und das ist das hier, das ist ja.
Genau, also äh sucht euch einfach die Studie aus, äh die ihr schon immer mal haben wolltet und glaubt, wie solche Aktionen kann man das dann auch da hinbringen, dass irgendwie solche Sachen einfach mal sofort aus irgendeinem rauspurzeln, weil was soll der ganze Geiz?
Das wäre schön, wenn.
Ja äh genau, also die man kann hoffen, dass eine solche Aktion,
denen irgendwann den irgendwann bringen, den die Erkenntnis bringt zu sagen, okay, wir dampfen jetzt einfach alle, weil diese Anfragen, die wir jetzt bekommen von vielen, vielen verschiedenen Einzelpersonen, denen wir dann auch nicht irgendwie großartig
was im Weg stellen können und jeden Antrag einzeln äh bearbeiten müssen oder so, wäre jetzt eigentlich zu hoffen,
Dass die, dass diejenigen ähm.
Einsehen, dass es.
Dass diejenigen einsehen und sagen, komm, ey, einmal hier, zack, gib einmal alles, die fragen eh alles, lass uns das jetzt hier online stellen und dann lassen sie uns hoffentlich in Ruhe.
Ja eben, ich meine, die machen sich auch nur Arbeit damit.
Ist Verwaltung und Verwalter werden verwalten, ja? Also kann auch gut sein, dass sie sagen, ähm machen wir.
Gut, ähm es war mal wieder Untersuchungsausschuss, ein Sitzungstag und ich muss zugeben, ich habe nichts davon mitbekommen,
Ich war komplett abgelenkt von anderen Sachen. Das war gestern, ne?
Gestern ja äh Donnerstag der sechsundzwanzigste nee der achtundzwanzigste. Ja.
Zwanzigste. Ja. Was da passiert? Da waren jetzt wieder ein paar BND Mitarbeiter mit kryptischen Abkürzungen.
Einer war zum vierten Mal da, der gute DB. Ähm.
Der der ist quasi der der zentrale Zeuge
bei den, bei allem, was mit mit Selektoren äh zu tun hat, ja? Und heute haben oder gestern haben sie sich insbesondere, also sie haben sich ja wieder stundenlang mit den Leuten da unterhalten, aber gestern ging es insbesondere.
Ähm um BND-Aktionen gegen ähm Partnerstaaten,
Ja? Ähm wir haben ja schon öfter darüber hier gesprochen, dass das der große Konflikt,
in diesem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss zwischen den Oppositionsvertretern und den Koalitionsvertretern.
War und ist inwiefern man seine Untersuchung auch in Richtung des BND und der der Aktivitäten des BND gegen Partnerstaaten richtet.
Und ähm,
die Opposition sagt im Prinzip, wir wollen das machen, die Koalitionsvertreter sagen, nee, wollen wir eigentlich nicht und dann hat die Opposition gesagt, na, wenn wir das nicht machen
dann äh klagen wir entweder oder wenn uns das mit dem Klagen irgendwie auf den Sack geht, dann.
Machen wir unseren eigenen.
Einen neuen Untersuchungsausschuss, Freunde, dann sitzen wir hier demnächst ähm an zwei Tagen die Woche und das wollt ihr ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Und äh es ist also jetzt als ein Entgegenkommen oder ein ein eine beschwichtigende äh,
Maßnahme der ja von wem auch immer zu werten,
dass jetzt der Offizier DB vom BND dort nochmal mehr äh zu seinen zu diesen Aktionen gesagt hat,
Und zwar ging es darum, wir wissen ja seit August zweitausendvierzehn ungefähr, dass der BND eben auch,
Partnerstaaten ausgespäht hat und jetzt ist die Frage, wann wussten das Kanzleramt,
und BND Chef Gerhard Schindler.
Wussten die das vielleicht sogar schon zu dem Zeitpunkt als Angela Merkel im Oktober zweitausenddreizehn sagte, dass das Aussperren unter Freunden ja gar nicht geht.
Und es stellte sich raus, dass Pofalla,
den also Kanzleramt, damaliger Kanzleramtschef Pofalla, den BND Chef Gerhard Schindler im im Oktober.
Angewiesen hat
das kritische BND Zielvorgaben mit den Botschaften und Regierungseinrichtungen von Partnerländern in Krisenregionen überwacht worden sein, deaktiviert werden sollten, also mit anderen Worten, Pofalla hat Schindler gesagt,
Wenn unter Freunden machen wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Das heißt, der Pofalla wusste zu diesem Zeitpunkt, dass sie das machen, sonst hätte er das ja nicht dem BND Schindler, BND-Chef Schindler gesagt, hört auf damit.
Und der BND-Chef Schindler hat diese Anweisung am achtundzwanzigsten Oktober,
Fernmündlich zur Sophia sofortigen Umsetzung an den DB weitergegeben,
Die Äußerung von Angela Merkel ausspielen unter Freunden, das geht gar nicht, war am vierundzwanzigsten Oktober.
Und jetzt stellen sich natürlich sehr interessante Fragen.
Wann genau hat der Pufffalla das dem Shindar gesagt, weißt.
Das genau, da wurde das genaue Datum nicht genannt.
Ah ja okay.
Ja? Äh aber es wäre jetzt also sie haben halt quasi genau, äh der hat's genau so erzählt, dass man jetzt theoretisch noch irgendwie die die es irgendwie
Der Schluss zulässig wäre, dass der Pofalla vielleicht am fünfundzwanzigsten gefragt hat und der Schindler selbst ist am sechsundzwanzigsten erfahren hat und am siebenundzwanzigsten den Pofalla gesagt hat und am achtundzwanzigsten äh entsprechend die äh die.
Die Anweisung fernmündlich, also ich meine, das ist ja wirklich mal eine eine sehr konkrete Anweisung, äh die da gegeben wurde, mit einer sehr weitreichende und wichtige
Ja, die wurde halt, da hat der Schindler halt auch schon gewusst, nee, sowas machen wir lieber fernmündlich. Nichts, dass das da nachher irgendwo eine Aktennotiz gibt, äh die oder irgendeine E-Mail, die irgendwo
es rauskommt. Also es verdichtet sich einfach sehr klar der,
dessen Netz, das Pofalla, das wusste und auch schon zu dem Zeitpunkt als Angela Merkel äh sich da ähm so dargestellt hat, ja, also es ist ja wirklich,
Also diese eigentlich kommt man sicher auch ein bisschen blöd vor,
dauerhaft immer um diese dieses Wer hat, wann was gewusst spielt, mitzuspielen. Ja, das musst du halt als ein rechtsstaatlich agierender Untersuchungsausschuss wahrscheinlich irgendwie machen, aber ähm als.
Die die,
Geschichte, dass da irgendwie alle die ganze Zeit nichts wussten. Hm die ist nun wirklich irgendwie langsam nicht mehr aufrechtzuerhalten und die war's ja irgendwie auch,
für rational die Sache betrachtende Menschen irgendwie zu keinem Zeitpunkt so wirklich.
Das äh ist so das Geschehen im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Ähm,
Gab noch ein paar andere Debatten, um technische Rahmenbedingungen und was da irgendwie stattfindet, aber wie wie immer äh sagt da so keiner genau, was irgendwie abgeht und,
Die Frage ist irgendwie, wie kriegt man jetzt diesen Schlüssel zeugen DB dazu, mal wirklich endlich auszupacken, was da los ist? Denn der versucht ja natürlich auch, die ganze Zeit irgendwie seinen eigenen,
Äh ruf irgendwie zu retten. Der muss da seine Vorgesetzten schützen. Und jetzt,
Wäre natürlich die Frage, kann man dem irgendwie so was wie so ein,
Zeugenschutzprogramm oder Straffreiheit anbieten, dass er mal wirklich jetzt endlich allumfassend aussagt. Und ähm das ist natürlich erstmal ein Mittel, was der Untersuchungsausschuss nicht zur Verfügung hat. Das ist ja einfach kein
Strafverfolgung des Gericht und ähm da wäre jetzt die Frage,
ob das tatsächlich ob an dem das irgendwie geben kann oder nicht. So die ähm die Einschätzung von Daniel Lücking beim Podcast technische Aufklärung, den ich gerade gehört habe.
Fällt mir immer wieder paar Mal so durch die Galaxis ein.
Wenn du jetzt anfängst zu reden oder was welche.
Da gibt's diesen, diese tolle Stelle mit Prag
den sie irgendwie die ganze Zeit dazu auffordert, doch endlich mal auszupacken. Und der soll doch jetzt mal endlich mal, der soll jetzt endlich mal die Wahrheit sagen so und äh
mit irgendwelchen Wahrheitsdrogen irgendwie vollpumpen und dann irgendwann fängt er dann halt wirklich an. Oh Gott, jetzt sagte er wirklich die Wahrheit und dann bauen sie halt irgendwie so eine riesige Mauer um ihn herum, damit irgendwie auch gar keiner mitbekommt, wie er dann irgendwie
ewig redet und gerade als er irgendwie fertig war mit seiner ganzen Aussage. Kommt dann irgendwie vorbei. Als lustige Szene.
Ja, also dieser NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, tja.
Wir werden es, wir werden es erleben. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob die das wievielte Mal die Bäder noch irgendwie hinholen werden. Gleichzeitig ähm.
Kriegt er natürlich auch durchaus Kritik der gute DB. Ich glaube, Herr.
Ähm war dann irgendwann so mit seinen Nerven am Ende, dass er ihm sagte, dieses schwarze Loch, was sie jetzt hier äh machen, da passiert ja, da fällt ja irgendwann noch alles rein.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was äh wie's wie's wird, wenn der Herr Steinmeier dann da ist.
Das wird sicherlich auch nochmal spannend.
Ist ja schon gebucht.
Ja, ähm ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob schon beim nächsten Mal, dass wir am achtzehnten zweiten, aber ich kann mal kurz schauen, was, wann er da erwartet wird,
Siebzehnter dritter erwartet man ihn, glaube ich, eher dort. So, so meine Informanten.
Will sie. Das war's zum Untersuchungsausschuss. Ja, war's.
Ja, nur noch kurzes Zitat von ähm,
von Fliesek im Wortlaut, wenn es so weitergeht, verschwinden wir bald alle in diesem schwarzen Loch, das sie produzieren. Sagte Fliesek zu äh DB.
Also zu zufrieden sind sie jetzt auch nicht unbedingt mit ihm. Ja, Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben wir ja auch noch.
Mhm. Da war doch was.
Ähm da war doch auch was mit der mit der Vorzeitenspeicherung. Da waren nämlich Verfassungsbeschwerden. Inzwischen ist die Zahl der Verfassungsbeschwerden irgendwie kaum noch zu überblicken. Das ist jetzt wohl irgendwie so.
Trend.
Zum guten Ton, ne? Man muss schon auch mal Einspruch gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung erhoben haben.
Ja, also es gibt irgendwie so eine äh es gab einen Artikel von
Spiegel Online vor Bundesverfassungsgericht wer alles gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung klagt mit 'nem schönen Foto wo irgendwie so Leute Schlange stehen am Bundesverfassungsgericht,
Ich hab's, ich habe den Artikel gelesen, den hast du jetzt auch nicht ganz verstanden. Also es gibt irgendwie FDP und.
Kanzleien und D vierundsechzig dieser SPD-Nahverein, aber die SPD hat irgendwie auch selber beschlossen, es gab aber jetzt eine,
relativ folgenschwere oder nichtfolgenschwere, aber eine wichtige Entscheidung, denn wenn ich es richtig rekonstruiert habe, sind vier der,
In ihrer Gesamtanzahl nicht unbedingt vollständig bekannten Verfassungsbeschwerden gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Mit einem sogenannten Eilantrag äh verbunden. Also vier Eilanträge gibt es insgesamt beim Bundesverfassungsgericht,
die Wiedereinführung der Eilantrag zu verhindern, beziehungsweise mindestens auszusetzen bis zu einer,
finalen Entscheidungen. Weißt du, ist das klar, was ich meine?
Ja, mir schon.
Okay, gut, dann dann werden's die anderen auch verstanden.
Und ein solcher wurde jetzt abgelehnt,
denn der Beschwerdebeschwerdeführer dessen Eilantrag hier abgelehnt wurde
wollte sich dagegen, also hat gesagt, er möchte bitte, dass die Provider vorläufig von der eigentlichen Pflicht zum Protokollieren von Verbindungs- und Standortdaten befreit werden sollen. Also, ne, dieses Gesetz soll
hat ein so hohes Schadenspotenzial, wenn es ähm vom.
Wenn es, wie wir vermuten, als Beschwerdeführer vom Bundesverfassungsgericht abgelehnt ist, dass wir bis zu der Entscheidung es ohnehin schon einmal nicht gültig machen,
sein lassen sollten,
Und in der Begründung der Ablehnung schreibt die dritte Kammer des ersten Senates,
dass der Antragsteller nicht erkennen lasse, dass ihm auf jeden Fall
Eine unzumutbar Schwere nicht wieder gut zumachende Nachteiligkeit entstünde, wenn dies der Fall wäre. Also selbst wenn die Speicherauflagen später als verfassungswidrig eingestuft würden,
sei der Schaden, der dem Antragsteller bis zu dem Zeitpunkt entstanden wäre, nicht unzumutbar.
Das ist ähm.
Jetzt wird's kompliziert.
Es ist äh schwierig. Ich vermute.
Ich vermute.
Dass sie die ähm.
Dass sie diese dass sie diese Argumentation darauf stützen, dass ja.
Die der Zugriff auf diese Daten.
Auf schwere Delikte beschränkt ist. Und dass sie deshalb sagen, na ja, ein lieber ähm Beschwerdeführer, es ist.
Unwahrscheinlich, dass auf deine Daten zugegriffen wird,
Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, an dem wir darüber entscheiden, ob die generelle Praxis in Ordnung ist. So würde ich vermuten, dass hier interpretiert wurde.
Dass sozusagen diese Eilbedürftigkeit nicht erkannt wird. Ja.
Also sie haben nur über die Eilbedürftigkeit entschieden,
Insgesamt gibt es aber, wie gesagt, vier derartige Anträge und es wurde jetzt über erstmal nur über einen entschieden. Jetzt kann man natürlich vermuten, dass über die anderen gleich ähnlich entschieden wird. Es sei denn, die haben signifikant andere Begründungen, aber wie gesagt, ich bin ganz ehrlich,
in diesem in diesem Dschungel der Verfassungsbeschwerden blicke ich
Ich selber gerade nicht ganz durch, weil das eben, wie gesagt, so ein Modeding zu sein scheint, ne? Wir haben die äh alten Platzhirsche ähm im Rennen, die auch schon die erste Vorratsseitenspeicherung zu Fall gebracht haben,
Ja, die haben also die Band nochmal zusammengebracht und äh,
eben auch viele andere, die da jetzt irgendwie aktiv sind. Digitalcourage D vierundsechzig. Ja, da das muss man, da muss man sich jetzt eben einbringen.
Mhm. Der Baum eigentlich auch dabei, erste FDP-Riege.
Es ist doch der, das ist doch der, der, der Favorit, der äh ja, der ist auf jeden Fall auch dabei, die die.
Am Ende werden sie ja auch nur eine eine Klage wirklich annehmen, ne? Wenn ich äh jetzt mit den Modus Operandi das Bundesverfassungsgericht äh richtig äh wenn ich das richtig erinnere, wie das äh funktioniert. Also die nehmen jetzt nicht irgendwie ganz viele Klagen an.
Die sehen, dass da viele äh angestürmt kommen, aber am Ende lassen die sich quasi nur auf eine ein.
Also ein Sprecher des Gerichtes sagte alle Verfahren werden nun abgearbeitet. Ein Entscheidungstermin ist derzeit allerdings nicht absehbar. Ähm und wie gesagt, die die Ablehnung des ersten Eilantrages hat,
keine Aussagekraft darüber, wie äh.
Wie die Chancen für diese Verfassungsbeschwerden stehen oder wie über die entschieden würde, ne? Weil sie ja, wie gesagt, nur sagen, falls dann, so.
Und ich bin, wie gesagt, leider kein Verfassungsrechtler
der genau sagen kann, wie das da jetzt weitergeht. Und wie ob das Gericht nun die ganzen Verfassungsbeschwerden in irgendeiner Form zusammenlegen wird oder nicht, da sollten wir vielleicht in in naher Zukunft nochmal ähm,
mit jemandem drüber reden, der da der da mehr äh mehr Wissen oder Erfahrung hat als wir.
Werden wir machen, wird das sich ein bisschen,
wenn sich da so ein bisschen der erste Staub gelegt hat. Weil ich denke, letzten Endes wird das Ganze noch ein bisschen dauern, ne. Also das ist jetzt sozusagen äh
Wer jetzt natürlich äh ganz interessant, wenn jetzt ein äh Eilantrag tatsächlich durchkommt, also wenn irgendjemand äh geschafft äh hätte, da eine Formulierung zu finden, wo das Verfassungsgericht auch sagt, oh ja, okay, äh Gefahrenverzug
zeichnet sich aber gerade noch nicht so ab oder macht zumindest so den Eindruck, als ob sie das noch nicht abzeichnen würde.
So, dann äh hat sich die GEMA äh gemeldet und musste eine kleine Niederlage eingestehen.
Also das ist ja das ist ja da blickt ja jetzt echt keiner mehr durch. Da musste ich jetzt echt nochmal recherchieren und auch da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob meine Recherchen da jetzt vollumfänglich waren. Ähm,
die Gamer will ja Geld von YouTube.
Und es gibt einmal Verfahren und Urteile in Hamburg,
und jetzt hat die Gamer aber auch irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen,
Eine Entscheidung des Landesgerichts München noch einmal dem Oberlandesgericht München vorgelegt. Also wir haben in Hamburg die Situation ähm,
da wurde geurteilt, YouTube könnte, könne unter Umständen haftbar gemacht werden, wenn ähm,
Die Videoplattform bestimmten Kontrollen bei hochgeladenen Musikvideos nicht nachkommt. Das hat Hamburg geurteilt. Da geht es um diese ganze Content ID Geschichte, ja, wo die GEMA im Prinzip YouTube ja verpflichten will, ähm.
Die hochgeladenen Videos zu kontrollieren und YouTube macht das ja auch auf eine gewisse Weise. Ähm.
Gleichzeitig hat Hamburg aber entschieden, die die Richter,
Äh er hat haben die Richter in Hamburg entschieden, dass YouTube nicht unmittelbar für die Inhalte verantwortlich ist, die auf seiner Seite existieren. Das ist das klassische, ich muss Kenntnis erlangen,
darüber, dass die Inhalte illegal sind, erst dann bin ich dafür haftbar als.
Content Provider, wo User Generation Content existiert. Was ja auch die sinnvolle Regelung ist, wir haben das immer öfter an dem Beispiel, wenn jetzt äh jemand bei ähm,
Logbuch Netzpolitik in den Kommentaren etwas schriebe, was irgendwie gerechtlich in,
Zwielicht steht, dann äh stünde, dann wären wir ab dem Moment der Kenntnis,
für diesen Inhalt verantwortlich jedoch nicht davor. Das heißt, wenn uns jemand schreibt, ey, übrigens da hier, ne, dann müsst dann, ab dann stünden wir in der Verantwortung,
eben auch diesen Inhalt dann zu löschen, vorher jedoch nicht,
Und das das Verfahren in Hamburg war irgendwie so, ja, aber YouTube müsse natürlich auch zumutbare Maßnahmen ergreifen, dass sowas von vornherein nicht passiert.
Das ist der Stand in Hamburg. Gleichzeitig ähm hat die GEMA aber einen Schadensersatzprozess gegen YouTube,
in München,
Und da waren sie im da sind sie auch im letzten Jahr vor dem Landgericht München unterlegen. Ähm weil die GEMA da von YouTube Geld haben wollte.
Und da sagten, sagte die GEMA, wir wollten äh wir wir hätten gerne von YouTube für den Abruf bestimmter Musikvideos durch Internetnutzer. Ähm,
bestimmter Musikvideos eben der, die irgendwie für die die Gamer sich irgendwie vertretungsberechtigt fühlt. Null Komma drei sieben fünf Cent für jeden Abruf.
Und dann haben sie so insgesamt äh hundert äh tausend ausgewählte Titel genommen und irgendwie einen Streitwert von eins Komma sechs Millionen Euro errechnet.
Und in München wurde geurteilt, im Land zunächst im Landgericht naja, die YouTube muss dafür gar nichts zahlen, weil die Nutzer und nicht die Plattformen für die veröffentlichen Veröffentlichung verantwortlich seien.
Und dann sind die, ist die GEMA in Berufung gegangen vom Oberlandesgericht München.
Das Oberlandesgericht hat ebenso entschieden.
Und jetzt will die will das will die GEMA mit dem Urteil vor den Bundesgerichtshof gehen. Ich frage mich, wie viel Geld die inzwischen da verbraten haben.
Na ja gut, ich meine aber dafür sind sie ja da.
Zu verbraten.
Ja nee, beziehungsweise da einfach so bissig zum zu zu bleiben und das einfach so lange.
Ja gut, das stimmt.
Dafür sammeln sie halt die ganze Kohle ein.
Ich dachte immer, sie würden das äh einsammeln, um den Künstlern irgendwie.
Na ja, also da es gibt so Sachen, da muss man vielleicht auch irgendwann einfach mal sagen, äh da sieht man jetzt drüber weg. Also der Rechtsstaat zwischen GEMA und YouTube, das ist jetzt wirklich.
Ja gut, aber ist natürlich ganz interessant, also äh was zeichnet sich hier ab? Es zeichnet sich äh ab, dass,
selbst in Deutschland die Sichtweise der GEMA nicht so ohne weiteres akzeptiert wird,
dass sie also nicht so ohne weiteres sagen kann, ja hier äh die Plattform hat äh zu zahlen oder hat vielleicht auch genau das zu zahlen, was wir uns äh vorstellen, sondern nur weil jetzt äh,
Material anderer oder wo andere Rechte dran besitzen auf einer Plattform veröffentlicht wird, ist es nicht automatisch
die Aufgabe äh oder die Verantwortung der der Plattform, sonst zählen am Ende immer noch die die User selber,
Das macht's natürlich nicht äh einfacher für die Gamer, gar keine Frage.
Na, die gehen wir die gehen wir in ihrer Pressemitteilung, denke ich, ah, schon ein,
ein Argument. Ne, sie sagen, wir fordern.
Von YouTube, Geld für die Verwertung unserer Videos.
YouTube zahlt uns keinerlei Lizenzvergütung für die Musiknutzung auf ihrer Videoplattform. Erwirtschaftet aber Werbeerlöse damit.
Ja.
Da sie Werbeerlöse erwirtschaften.
Verwertet YouTube? Nach unserer Auffassung, diese Werke.
Und eine Verwertung der Werke ist Vergütungspflichtig.
Sie sagen quasi dadurch, dass YouTube dort wirbt, ist YouTube nicht nur ein reiner technischer Dienstleister, sondern verhält sich wie ein Musikdienst.
YouTube gibt das Video zur Verfügung Werbung wird eingeblendet, YouTube verdient damit Geld,
Daher soll YouTube bitte schön auch die Lizenzen erwerben ähm und nicht die Verantwortung für den Upload an die Uploader weitergeben. Das ist erstmal eine Argumentation, der ich sogar folgen kann.
Ja, ich auch.
Vermutlich waren sie nur so blöd, sich Beispiele rauszusuchen, wo YouTube genau keine Werbung macht,
Also ich kann mir, ich kann mir andererseits nicht vorstellen, dass YouTube so blöd ist, bei dieser Gamermusik dann auch noch Werbung einzublenden
Na ja, also das Oberlandesgerichtsurteil ist noch nicht rechtskräftig. Eine Revision wurde zugelassen und ähm die Gamap wird jetzt
Urteilsbegründung eingehend studieren und dann voraussichtlich eine Revision einlegen, auf das wir auch hier in diesem Rechtsstreit ähm
zukünftig auf neue Meldungen ähm hoffen können.
Diesem spannenden Thema.
Diesen spannenden Thema.
Gut, das äh bringt uns ans Ende dieser Sendung. Ja. Das wird auch Zeit.
Wir wollen ja hier nicht so übermäßig lang machen.
Ich wollte mal noch eins sagen, unsere Facebook-Seite, ne? Also die Facebook dot com, äh Logbuch Netzpolitik, die ist seit ein paar Tagen in einem wirklich schmerzhaften Zustand, denn also.
Wir haben eine Facebook-Seite.
Ja, wir haben Facebook-Seite habe ich doch mal gemacht hier. Sie hat exakt eintausenddreihundertachtunddreißig Likes.
Ist doch geil.
Nein, eintausenddreihundertsiebenunddreißig wäre in Ordnung.
Aber eintausenddreihundertachtunddreißig ist echt also entweder.
Also irgendeiner irgendeiner muss jetzt sein Like zurücknehmen.
Entweder irgendeiner nimmt den Like jetzt zurück oder wir haben nächste Woche dreiundzwanzig zweiundvierzig da stehen, also zweitausenddreihundertzweiundvierzig Likes, das wäre auch noch akzeptabel, aber,
Sowas, ne? Wir machen uns so eine Arbeit.
Hier macht sich überhaupt keine Arbeit.
Jetzt wird da so draufgeschissen. Das finde ich nicht akzeptabel. Also das ist.
Du dir denn da für eine Arbeit?
Ich habe da äh weißt du, was das für eine Arbeit ist?
Dich dabei diesen Shady Diensten anzumelden, die dann da irgendwie automatische Posts und so machen. Das ist alles, das blickt doch keiner durch. Und dann musst du auf diese Facebook-Seite gehen und jedes Mal, wenn da einer irgendwas,
Facebook oder so oder liked, dann äh ist ihr in dieser App,
irgendeinen blinken und ich weiß immer nicht, ob da jetzt eine Handlung erforderlich ist oder nicht. Und ähm das ist das ist schon ähm belastend.
Ach, das ist doch alles Dreck, dieses ganze Facebook, das funktioniert dahinter.
Also, pass auf, wir machen das ganz einfach, wenn du nächste Woche nicht zweitausenddreihundertzweiundvierzig Likes sind, dann machen wir den den Sack zu. Oder? Sollen wir das jetzt mal einfach sagen? Nächste Woche, so, zweitausenddreihundertzweiundvierzig Likes.
Du, ich bezweifle ernsthaft, dass das, dass es uns irgendwie groß was bringt. Und äh davon abgesehen ähm kann es ja wahrscheinlich auch nur was bringen, wenn wir uns, wenn wir uns.
Wir haben hundertneunundsiebzig Beitragsinteraktionen.
Was soll denn das heißen?
Wenn wir da, weiß ich nicht, aber wenn wir, wenn wir was andere, wenn wir das ähm wenn wir hier klicken zwanzig Euro, dann werden das mehr. Steht hier.
Das ist ein Haus, ne. Personen, denen gesamt mit nee, vierzehn Euro.
Das ist auch ein schönes, schönes Beispiel, ne, wieder so wie
sowie Netzneutralität, ne, wenn so die Telekom beklagt so, ja, na ja, wir müssen ja so viel investieren und so weiter. Äh wäre auch schade, wenn ihr Videostream da irgendwie äh unter die Räder kommt, weil dann dann könnte es ja ruckeln. Im Prinzip macht,
macht Facebook ja mit ihrem Kanal genau das Gleiche. Sie könnten ja, wenn ich jetzt was poste,
Können sie das ja allen möglichen Leuten zugänglich machen, von denen ich das gerne möchte, ne? Alle Leute, die da geliked haben und was nicht alles, aber sie beschränken das halt nach irgendeinem komischen Algorithmus, sagen.
Kein Algorithmus, die der Algorithmus heißt, dividiere durch große Zahl und gib's nur so wenigen Leuten.
Na ja klar, also irgendsoein, ne, irgend so eine Reduzierung und dann kannst du dafür bezahlen, dass dann sozusagen diese Drossel, diese Kommunikationsdrossel aufgehoben wird.
Unbegreiflich, mir ist das alles unbegreiflich, dass man da.
Also.
Du möchtest gerne eintausenddreihundertsiebenunddreißig Beitragsinteraktionen haben.
Genau, ich möchte ein, also eintausenddreihundertsiebenunddreißig Beitragsinteraktionen und äh zweitausenddreihundertzweiundvierzig gefällt mir Angaben. Sonst machen wir net zu. Nee, Beitrag ist Interaktion nicht, dann piept das Telefon keine Beitrags.
Dein Telefon piept, wenn auf Facebook was passiert.
Überhaupt nicht haben, was wir überhaupt nicht haben sind registrieren und Webseitenklicks. Wir haben einen von allen Reaktion Quote. Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Linus, ich verstehe nichts davon. Das, das ist einfach, das ist eine Sprache, die die bei mir einfach null resoniert. Ich ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wovon die reden.
Deswegen, weißt du.
Könnten das so einfach machen und sie machen's nicht einfach und was soll das denn? Es ist alles albern.
Hey, schreibt uns auf Twitter und fertig. Das passt schon. Und dann und natürlich gerne hier in unsere äh Kommentare und so.
Aber Tim, dass die Jugend ist da drin.
Ach, die Jugend ist da drin. Die Jugend ist da drin verloren.
Die Hugen muss raus aus Facebook.
Bewirb deine Seite für fünf Euro. Fünf Euro.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Also während Linus hier sein letztes Hab und Gut auf Facebook schmeißt, das ist das ist so weißt du, früher, also früher sind sone Leute.
Du da angeknotet.
Ne früher sind solche Leute ins Casino gegangen. Ach komm, ich setze einfach auf rot und so. Das wird schon, da wird schon was werden. Ne, und, und, und heute hast du heißt Facebook Beitragsinteraktions äh äh Lotterie,
und und und da wirst du dann die Kohle los. Einfach die ganze Zeit nur, weil du irgendwie, ja, ich muss ja irgendwie groß rauskommen können.
Ich verstehe das auch alles nicht. Also ich kann da nichts zu sagen. Wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt hier die Ziele, ich habe jetzt hier die die Planziele für die nächste Woche bekanntgegeben. Ansonsten wird hier Kraft meines Amtes äh wird der Facebook zugemacht. Vorausgesetzt, man kann das.
Wahrscheinlich muss man da auch für bezahlen.
Stop stop stop. Wir sagen jetzt tschüss Linus.
Ihr sagt tschüss. Ciao ciao.
Bis bald.